vous avez besoin de légumes ils ont
besoin de travail c'est en partant de ce
principe que sont nés les Jardins de
Cocagne des jardins maréchés biologiques
à vocation d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle manger bio manger
solidaire en quelque sorte il en existe
120 en France une vingtaine en projet
également bonsoir alaingérard vous êtes
le directeur des Jardins de Cocagne sur
Mani Lamo le site de Mani Lamo qui a vu
le jour en 2010 quel bilan vous en
faites 1 an et demi 2 ans d'exploitation
un peu plus même un bilan positif
puisqueaujourd'hui on est à 150
adhérents en panier hebdomadaire qu'on a
commencé à 40 adhérents côté très
positif c'est qu'on est reconnu
maintenant dans le paysage social et
économique tant au niveau de
Saint-Quentin que de manie que du
conseil régional et général alors au
niveau national 4000 jardiniers 20000
familles adhérentes 750 en cadrant 1500
bénévoles quelques chiffres sur manie
alors sur manie on a donc 18 personnes
en insertion 6 encad 6 encadrant qui se
correspondent encadrant technique des
personnes qui font une proximité
deapprentissage du métier une
conseillère en insertion et un
responsable adhérent parce que c'est
important pour nous c'est également 4
hear et demi de culture ce qui est
important 150 adhérents
hebdomadaires 200 adhérents total parce
qu' une carte une partie adhérents
hebdomadaire une partie boutique donc
voilà des chiffres justement comment ça
fonctionne parce qu'il y a adhérents
permanents ces adhérents ponctuels voilà
qui peuvent venir au fur à mesure
comment ça marche le jardin de cocag
pour ceux qui ne connaîtrai pas encore
alors le jardin de cocag c'est d'abord
un abonnement c'est que la personne qui
devient adhérent est un consommateur
acteur ce qu'on appelle chez nous donc c
33 € d'abonnement annuel permettent soit
d'avoir un panier hebdomadaire à 16 €
par semaine soit d'avoir accès à une
boutique où il y a des légumes de
produits tous les jours alors les so
d'ouverture c'est de 16h à à 19h le
mardi et le vendredi exclusivement et là
vous rencontrez également les personnes
qui sont non jardiners et qui recherche
un emploi et qui chez nous retrouve un
dynamique et un projet professionnel al
parce que les jardiniers que vous
embauchez sont là pour des périodes
courtes sont des CDD de 6 mois c'est ça
alors c'est des CDD de 6 mois
renouvelable une fois c'est un an
maximum chez nous on est juste un
trempelin vers un projet professionnel
l'idée c'est de réinsérer
progressivement leur montrer comment ça
fonctionne dans une entreprise des
horaires de travail par exemple tout à
fait il faut savoir que chez nous ils
ont une période de décès d'un mois et
dès que la période décès est passée
immédiatement on les accompagne sur le
projet professionnel sachant que 6 mois
c'est très très court et donc on met
tout en œuvre pour qu'il réussisse je
dirais au bout de 8 à 9 mois il se
tourne vers quel type de profession
justement il reste dans le même domaine
ça leur permet de découvrir des
vocations ou pas forcément pas forcément
qu'on a à peu près 20 % de personnes qui
restent dans le maréchage principalement
c'est logistique restauration entretien
ces principaux métiers vers lesquels ces
personnes se s'orientent du fait de leur
qualification principalement succès
grandissant pour les Jardins de Cocagne
nombre d'adhérents augmente vous nous le
disiez ça fonctionne très bien et puis
ça permet donc de mener cette initiative
de réinsertion ce weekend vous avez mené
des portes ouvertes vous étiez nombreux
et nous y étions également en rencontre
avec Gérard et Guy ce sont deux des
salariés justement qui sont en
réinsertion sur ce site et on se
retrouve ensuite sur le plateau avec le
directeur de manie lesamo
alaingérard depuis 3 mois Gérard
travaille au Jardin de Cocagne à Manil
et àot une association d'insertion loi
1901 qui cultive des légumes bio
distribuer chaque semaine à des
adhérents consommateurs sous forme de
panier comme la plupart de ses collègues
Gérard a intégré les jardins suite à une
période de chômage une manière de ne pas
rester inactif ben retrouver goû
retrouver des personnes des gens avec
qui je peux parler discuter et puis bien
rigoler comme mes collègues font
derrière et puis c'est super bien quoi
c'est reprend de goû au travail pour
certains les jardins c'est également
l'occasion d'envisager une reconversion
Guy a travaillé pendant 12 ans dans les
pompes funèbres du jour au lendemain il
s'est retrouvé sans travail orienté par
Paul emploi il a frappé à la porte des
Jardins de Cocagne en mars 2011 et
découvert le métier qu'il souhaiterait
exercer marécher moi ici mon quotidien
ben c'est travailler tous les jours ici
c'est super je change de travail je fais
des motes des motes de terre que de
terreot que je saime déjà dans dans la
serre ici puis que je récolte en 2012
plusieurs personnes ont déjà récolté les
fruits de leur travail quatre ont trouvé
un emploi et de une formation
qualifiante grâce au suivi de
l'association Gérard a obtenu un
entretien s'il est positif il intégrera
une enseigne de grande distribution dans
un mois quant à Guy il entame son deè
CDD de 6 mois au jardin plus motivé que
jamais pour faire de sa nouvelle passion
un
métier on a vu deux exemples avec deux
salariés qui travaillaient sur le site
les résultats sont sont bons justement
les gens retrouvent assez facilement
ensuite malgré le contexte économique
aussi j'ai envie de dire un travail
derrière ce n'est pas aussi facile que
ça là on a deux cas très positifs non
c'est pas une formule magique on a des
échecs aussi mais on a aussi des grands
succès et notre plus grande force c'est
vraiment de travailler à
l'accompagnement de ces personneslà et
surtout de valoriser de sortir leur
projet sur lorsqu'ils ont pris confiance
en eux c'est ça le plus important après
on peut les aider à retrouver un emploi
malgré le suivi après même une fois
mettons les deux CDD passé de 6 mois
tout à fait on accompagne toujours les
personnes même après s'il y a des des
problèmes autre je dirais alors ça se
développe à peu partout en France il y
en une vingtaine encore de jardins de
cocain qui sont en projet vous
fonctionnez en réseau avec les autres
justement où chacun fonctionne dans son
coin sachant qu'il y a tout même une
charte aussi très précise he qui doit
s'appliquer tout à fait de toute façon
pour être jardin de Cocagne il faut
adhérer à une charte du réseau très
précise et si on adhère pas on peut pas
te agréer jardin Cocagne alors dans la
Charte invocation d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle de personnes en
difficulté production de légumes
cultivés en agriculture biologique
commercialisation de ces légumes auprès
d' d'un réseau d'indérant l'intégration
la filière locale également de
l'agriculture biologique tout ça c'est
respecté à la lettre tout à fait
exactement nous sommes très proches des
agriculteurs qui sont autour de nous
également et très proches de tout tout
secteur économique et social et chaque
site peut développer aussi des des
activités en parallèle des choses
spécifiques est-ce qu'il y a des
particularités par
exempleoc tout à fait chaque site a sa
particularité ENF qui est donné par son
directeur principalement
c'est qu'on travaille de plus en plus
avec les entreprises notamment ce qu' le
terme j'aime pas beaucoup le team
bulding mais qui est efficace si faire
une liaison entre les personnes qui sont
ns jardiners et les entreprises qui
viennent découvrir le le jardin et je
prendre un bol d'air pour eux également
c'est difficile de rentrer en tant que
salarié justement est-ce qu'il y a une
liste d'attente est-ce qu'ils sont
nombreux à vouloir entrer pour faire de
l'insertion sur oui c'est très compliqué
enfin c'est pas compliqué mais qu'il a
beaucoup de demandes on a des places on
a tro à qure places par mois
sachant tout à fait tout à fait sachant
que les personnes qui peuvent rentrer
chez nous sont les demands d'emploi de
longue durée ou des personnes RSA qui
sont prescrits par pô emploi ou orienté
vers par les plis les assistant sociales
principalement merci algérard d'être
venu sur ce plateau directeur des
Jardins de Cocagne c'est la fin de cette
édition du 78 on se retrouve on se
retrouve dès demain 18h en direct bonne
soirée